love you man
I don't care what they say you're doing
the best you can if they get your letter
help we'd be much better you doing a
good job it get a little hack team but
we love him but we need him to step up
and do a little bit more because these
kids I heard they need to be in school
and work I said I heard on the streets
cuz they know that no one gang banging
in jail all this oh yeah he need to step
up and mr. president I wrote a slogan
about you when you was running and it's
called rock Obama was man with rainbow
blood inside of him that way he is the
man to make the change cuz he could
blend in with the world mr. president
Oh broken I need some money
and so was the rest of this country
think you can help us out
I've been looking for work and I haven't
been able to find work I just want to
ask you you know saying is is there
gonna be any more jobs you don't saying
available for you know the ones that you
know that's over 50 years old they don't
want to hire people over 50 years old
we've been looking for you but you know
we've been seeing what's going on
everybody out here for you hey President
Obama you need to get some of these
stores a trap stores closed down our
neighborhoods I'm tired of seeing him
come over get money and playing us and
talk to us any kind of way and we don't
want to spend more money and they stores
with them so you need to do something
about that you gonna do anything
what love reasoner love sweet love love
you I'm hoping president cabeza it's
better for me my conditions with welfare
my brother just got shot by the police
and I don't think nothing really been
done about it
the police is always don't ever give
away for nothing and I think that need
to be fixed so Brooke I need you to help
us with this please stand for Molina and
help me to have a pirate in a safe place
to stay Thank You mr. president
my name is Molina and Molina Nene
raspberry we need more resources foot
and said the Chicago area period we need
you you are Chicago I guess it's cool to
have a black president but ain't none
change the violence then went up and I
don't know Pollock's other people
legalize marijuana for self I think you
do a great job in making sound wise
decisions thanks to you we have
Obamacare a lot of people don't
understand what it is designer maybe
they just weed into would it keep
understanding it they will know I think
that's a good thing you've done for us
happy new year I love rock Obama cuz I
love them and keep on don't stop now I
done you still be homing when they get
out there right now and come back home
to Chicago I see you later partner
cuz I got to go it's cold out here okay